[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning everyone welcome back to
the best business show i'm super excited
today we have a very special episode
myself and michael saylor sitting down
for a two-hour in-person conversation
michael and i recorded a podcast episode
about a year ago
right after he announced that he was
going to put a very material portion of
his company's balance sheet into bitcoin
and so maybe michael we can start with
kind of a one-year update from when you
actually decided to make that uh
decision and how things have been going
so far with uh microstrategy
sure um
well if you roll the clock back
to july
we had 500 million dollars of capital in
our treasury
we were holding short dated treasury
securities and generating effectively
like 20 basis points of yield on it
we've seen a k-shape recovery
wall street came back with the vengeance
main street was
was flat on its back
and
it was clear there's monetary inflation
so we decided that we
were going to lose a large portion of
the 500 million in purchasing power if
we didn't do something my forecast then
was probably like 25
inflation like and you could have got
there just by looking at the s p index
so i thought you know 500 million minus
25 like losing
125 million dollars in 12 months
is kind of like losing money at 2 to 3 x
the rate that the 2000 people in the
company were making money
so
we either needed to give the money back
to the shareholders or we needed to
invest in something
so
you know the thought was well
if we're a company straw a main street
company struggling against all the
lockdowns with all the uncertainty and
we
are doing it minus 500 million dollars
yeah it feels like a university giving
up its endowment as it goes into a
crisis right so
decapitalizing the company
it it was a way to give the 500 million
of shareholders they would have put in
the s p 500 and they would have got 34
percent on it
if we had done that
but we would have in essence left our
ourselves defenseless without any
capital so
that was one strategy the second was
invested all
um
i would have bought 500 million worth of
bitcoin if
if i was a private company i just would
have walked out
bought all 500 million i would have done
it at whatever 10 000 a coin
but as a public company you got to think
about your outside shareholders
and you can't it's not like there's 10
you can't just go to the tent of mask
them what they want to do and get their
buy-in when you're public
you've got a shifting set of outside
shareholders that are changing every
minute of the day when the stock market
is open
so the way that you actually handle this
is a bit more
more um sophisticated what we did is we
transparently
we telegraphed that we were looking at
this our first press release was an
announcement that we were going to
buy back 250 million dollars worth of
our stock over the course of 12 months
and we were going to invest 250 million
dollars of our capital in hard assets
and we said we're looking at everything
under the sun and bitcoin was one of the
things
so i
my first love of the bitcoin community
was the way that i knew i liked all the
bitcoiners was was one day later some
cyber hornet some bitcoiner goes
microstrategy is considering buying
bitcoin with 250 million dollars
now as bitcoin merged in there with gold
silver commodities equity property real
estate anything you could have imagined
but the bitcoin community immediately
picked up on that i don't know how they
do that right they must be scanning for
this
nobody else picked up on it the stock
was trading 120 a share
a week goes by
literally you announce you're going to
spend 250 million dollars and buy your
stock like you think it would move nope
crickets
um
but the market had a week of notice and
then a week later we stepped it up into
the next gear which is
okay
we're gonna buy 250 million dollars
worth of bitcoin we made the decision
we're not splitting it across six assets
right
and it's a good thing we did right
because uh bitcoin's up 332 in 12 months
gold is down
7
if we'd split it 50 50 125 million of
gold 125 million of bitcoin
right it would have cost us billions
if we'd gone all gold it would have cost
us many many many billion billions we'll
come back to that in a second
so so we had to do something but the
question is what so we just picked
bitcoin we made the decision but we
thought this is going to be jarring for
some people
stock is around 122 at the time
right to put this in perspective the
company's 500 million dollar revenue
generator generating cash flow
and um we have more than 500 million in
cash
and about 10 million shares so the
company's trading one times revenue plus
cash
we give back all the cash the company
trades at one times revenue the stock
goes to 60 bucks a share
right so we're like 122 no one's really
paying attention but we said well maybe
people think this is offensive they're
not gonna like this or it's too risky
how do you actually orange pill
every one of your outside shareholders
at the same time
well you can't
so
the next best thing is we just offered
to buy them out
so the idea is if you don't like this
we're going to buy buy you out we're
going to post 250 million dollars to buy
back shares at a premium
so we offered to do the buy back at up
to 140 a share
which is you know
buyout premium if you don't like it then
you sell your shares back to us at a
profit
we wait 20 days
so the market trades for 20 days and you
know in the first week the market's
trading on 135
like people so they're not even they're
not even quite sure about the bio then
after after a while they start thinking
they're like well if i can put it back
to the company at 140
then presumably
maybe it's worth more so the stock
trades up a bit past the 140.
and at the end of the tender period we
have uh
about 60 million dollars worth of shares
tendered
everyone that didn't like the strategy
had 20 days of selling to the open
market and if you sold in the open
market above 140 then why wouldn't you
and if you're still holding the shares
at the end of the tender period and you
don't like the strategy you sell under
the tender
so the result of the dutch auction is we
had 175 million dollars of extra capital
you know
we thought about it we put another press
release
okay this is our primary treasury
reserve asset
so the the first notch was this is a
treasury reserve asset
the second step is this is the primary
treasury reserve asset then we bought
175 million more bitcoin so that point
we're up to 425
million uh the first tranche is in the
11
500 range
uh that was that was a little bit
difficult it was more difficult to do
the second tranche because bitcoin
traded down we had a loss it traded down
to like you know into the tens and even
yeah you remember that so the second
tranche we bought at nine at 10 000
something
uh because we're committed right and and
you know if you go pull the twitter
stream there's all sorts of interesting
commentary on our our you know
strategy so you basically had done let's
call it up to that point 425 million of
a 500 million dollar balance sheet and
you had rotated your shareholder base to
people who were aligned with the
strategy and you had also planted the
flag in the ground as the first publicly
traded business in the united states to
identify uh a treasury strategy that
would leverage bitcoin as the primary
currency or the primary asset that you
would use in your treasury when you do
all that
i know that there's been a whole bunch
of conversations in the uh kind of
behind the curtain i don't need names
but what are other fellow publicly
traded companies other finance
executives people on wall street at that
point are they saying you're crazy are
they oh wait this is really interesting
tell me more about it trying to learn
like what was the reaction after the
first 425 million dollars i think it was
largely ignored by every other publicly
traded company i i don't think there's a
lot of awareness or
to it when we did our due diligence
checks
we found overstock two or three years
ago had a few million dollars of bitcoin
on his balance sheet
and that's it right we couldn't find
anybody else um
and uh and so this is off the beaten
path but it seemed like so rational to
me like it seems so obvious bitcoin is
is digital gold
it's basically engineered to be digital
gold what do you need in
a inflationary environment you need
something that's like gold but better
than gold
you have to make a choice
uh it was obvious that
the institutions were coming right i
mean you had
you had companies like fidelity getting
into the space
just you know six months earlier or
whatever but the fact that we're
institutional custodians was a big check
box grayscale was doing good business at
that time so
so
it struck me as being a rational thing
to do but no other public companies had
done it and it wasn't
it wasn't
totally clear to me why although at this
point now it becomes clear right in
hindsight
so
we went through that we did the 425
million uh the stock traded up bitcoin
started trading up
at that point i started speaking in
public and you know you were the first
person i spoke to
i remember right
and and you know i learned most of what
i knew about bitcoin by by uh scouring
the internet and looking at your podcast
looking at reading all of the stuff that
was posted right and i tripped through
all these different things
and uh one thing i knew from your
podcast was
you always ask the question
right
you know at the end right you're like
you can ask me a question remember
correct now you get to ask me the one
question so what i remembered about pomp
was he wants to know a book and he wants
uh and he wants
a question or he gives me a question so
i'm like gosh what question am i going
to ask pomp
and
you know how do you learn bitcoin you
study twitter and you study youtube and
you surf the web so here's what i know
i know i get to ask you a question and i
know jack dorsey has bitcoin in his bio
so the question is how do we how do we
get jack dorsey to buy bitcoin next
correct right correct
and uh you know at that point
we're all alone is a publicly traded
company and people aren't quite sure if
we're crazy but what happens next is
some bullish things right i mean
i thought that um
when square bought
bitcoin
that was a seminal event
right because one data point is a
question mark but when you had the
second data point you can draw a line
and so that was a big day
um when uh paypal
announced support for bitcoin
and they started uh sort of moving it
that was a big day that was a data point
right those were the data points
that moved us from 10 000 to 12 000 a
coin
and uh
at some point you know somebody some uh
citron research studied uh you know
discovered my stock and
andrew left i guess said something
positive and uh the stock started
trading up and then it traded into the
high 100s and then it
it traded into the 200s and and bitcoin
started trading up and when we got into
the teens
people thought well there's something
interesting here
so the next step in our journey was like
in addition to me starting to
communicate why we had done what we done
the next step in the journey was to go
out and buy more bitcoin so we started
buying more bitcoin as part of the
treasury reserve strategy and that got
people's attention
then um
when the stock got to the 300 range
that was the highest it's been in a
decade
300. so
we started thinking well maybe we can
raise more money and so we went back to
the convert market and we had
we were trying to raise 400 million
dollars in a convertible debt offering
but it was extremely popular
and we were oversubscribed so we upsized
the deal to
650 million dollars so that was a
screaming home run we
we had uh we had proposed a 32
to 37 premium we priced it at the 37.5
premium the high end of the spread
we proposed
like
1.25 to 0.75 percent interest we priced
at the low end of the
of the interest rate so we raised 650
million dollars at 75 basis points
with a strike price of 398. the stock
had not traded at 398 in a decade so it
seemed like reasonable if you could sell
650 million dollars of stock at 398
dollars a share seemed like a reasonable
thing to do at the time
so then we took that we bought bitcoin
with that so that was
we started out with um
with we're going to raise the money for
general corporate purposes and
along the way the discussion was what
are you going to do with it i said well
you know i want to be able to buy
bitcoin with it and they said well we
should put that you know into the
disclosure i said yeah we should
disclose that
and then they said well are you sure
you're going to buy it i said yeah so
eventually it flipped and it became
we're doing it to buy the bitcoin so
that became
in the history of first right we're the
first public company to buy bitcoin on
the balance sheet where the first public
company the declarative treasury reserve
asset we became the first public company
to do a dutch auction which is in
essence like an equity issuance to buy
bitcoin right it's like i'm either
buying my equity back or i'm uh or or
issuing the equity so with the first
dutch auction
you know where the proceeds eventually
became bitcoin then the first
convertible bond to buy bitcoin
and uh i think that all of those things
rotated the shareholder base right
i think um
the most important thing was to be long
bitcoin right so in essence the first
publicly traded company where the
shareholder bases is long bitcoin
and it started out my aspiration was
it'd be great if half of our
enterprise value is based upon
enterprise software
and half is based upon the assets
because before we did this
we got substantially no credit for the
assets
like people are basically taking the 500
million and they're like okay well
that's going to be worth zero
right or negative because you were one
times revenue plus uh just the cash on
the balance sheet yeah
yeah so
um if you've got a low growth cash cow
right that that's like being a dentist
where you're going to make a lot of
money every year for a decade and maybe
you'll make five percent more each year
for a decade if you've got a low growth
cash cow but the money supply is
debasing at 25 a year
it kills you right
it's like the road to serfdom is working
exponentially harder for a currency
getting exponentially weaker
what i saw was 2 000 people
doing a hundred thousand things right
every year
to make 50 million dollars
and then watching the enterprise lose
a hundred million dollars a year
due to a political decision so in
essence we're running as hard as we can
we're falling backwards and the
situation was literally hopeless right
like people
wonder where the bitcoin is hope come
from
well it just was hopeless right i mean
the operating business is hopeless and
and
you know okay you know you're going to
work yourself to death for a decade and
do a million things right with 2 000
people and you're going to be worse off
in a decade than you are today
that's operationally hopeless right
that's
and then on the balance sheet
if somebody says we're not even thinking
about thinking about raising interest
rates
it means for the next four years you're
going to get zero percent on your money
and is going to be worth
half as much
in 36 months as it is worth today
the balance sheet is hopeless
and this is all before we even see the
persistently high inflation that we're
seeing now right this was just from a
market structure standpoint of uh this
had been going on
pre-kovid
got accelerated during covet you started
to recognize this again last year if you
go back and look at the inflation
numbers in q3 q4 i mean it was obvious
that we were in uh increasing or
accelerating but we weren't at five
percent cpi for three four five months
right now's a much much different
situation
so at what point do you switch from this
as purely a defensive like treasury
strategy of we want to take the cash on
our balance sheet and put it in an asset
that uh we can protect ourselves protect
our purchasing power
to then it feels like you made the
switch to go offensive that first bond
offering was an offensive i think you
called it right there i think that it's
a defensive strategy uh through the
dutch auction we had to do the dutch
auction to provide a graceful transition
for our shareholders to get long bitcoin
right you're either long bitcoin or
you're selling out to us at a premium
one or the other
and then from that point bitcoin started
moving up and
our stocks started moving up and then we
realize that we
like the conservative thing to do is
just stop there
and if we stopped there i mean we would
be
all equity 475 million dollars invested
at a
thousand dollars a coin or something and
that's not a bad result right we would
have made six extra money
but um what we realized is we could
borrow money at 75 basis points
and we and
you know bitcoins up 171 a year every
year for a decade right
if you can borrow money at one percent
and invested 171 percent your arbitrage
is 170 on how much well how how much do
you want right like where are you going
to stop that when you borrowed at the 75
basis points i was impressed but then
you followed it up and you borrowed even
more at a zero percent interest rate if
i remember correctly
what was the second offering
because the first offering came out the
strike was 398 bitcoin kept moving up
our stock kept moving up
eventually that bond was the best
performing bond of the entire year
right anthony what i'm saying is of
every single corporate bond sold in the
year 2020 every convert
every junk bond everything sold every
municipal bond whatever you could
imagine the single best performing bond
was microstrategy convertible bond which
where you would have you could have
doubled your money you know at some
point is trading insane amounts like
triple
you know your money on a bond okay so we
had good success there and of course
bitcoin kept moving up
and our stock up moving up and
we realized by february that we could do
another offering the next offering uh
was we came in the market offering 600
million dollars the first one we started
with 400 million this time we started
600 million but again it was
oversubscribed we upsized it exercised
the green shoe it became a 1 billion 50
million offering
and the range was 50 basis points to
zero so we struck it as zero
and uh
you know uh up 50 37 i forget the number
but we ended up having a 50 premium
or 47
i forget exactly it was a high premium
it was a low coupon the strike price was
fourteen hundred thirty two dollars a
share so now put this in perspective
this is ten times
the price of the dutch auction
[Music]
you know some number of months earlier
now um
so why'd we do that well because if you
could borrow a billion dollars at zero
percent interest and invested in
something going up 170 percent a year
pretty good trading why wouldn't you do
it right uh like every single business
on earth that's debt financed presumably
is borrowing money to invest in
something which is going to return a
higher yield than the cost of the debt
now this i want to pause here and make
one point
the reason that i was sensitive to
inflation
like
was
i immediately saw the inflation in march
and april in the stock market
right because my inflation bogey wasn't
if i were to go to all my uh investors
and say i got 500 million dollars i'm
investing in a 2 interest and inflation
rates 1 percent
they wouldn't have given me a pat on the
back they would have said the s p index
is moving up ten percent a year your bur
your hurdle rate your cost of capital is
not one percent or two percent it's ten
percent
and maybe you're getting five percent
yield on uh on a piece of debt then i
don't hold my nose but you're losing
five percent a year
half-life of the money is 12 years
okay fine but like you shouldn't be
holding you should be you should be
buying your stock back or buying another
company with that sitting on that cash
is
it doesn't make any sense
safety says
the dollar weighted
monetary inflation rate across you know
all all currencies for the last 30 years
is 14
interesting number he comes up with 14
is the inflation rate of
the currencies now that would be the
inflation rate on scarce desirable
assets or any portfolio of assets and if
i look at my screen right now over the
last 10 years the s p 500 is showing
14.15 percent interest a 14.15 percent
compounded annual growth rate
nasdaq's up you know whatever 19
you know uh gold is up
20 basis points
nothing
bitcoin is up 170 base
170 right and long bonds give you like
two and a half percent
so the monetary inflation rate equals
the s p index well yeah that the
traditional way you'd value um
a stock
is
you would put a risk premium on it and
you would say
well your cost of capital is the return
plus the risk premium so
it used to be we think well there's a
three percent risk premium and the
inflation rate then would be 11
but i think that if you buy the s p
index you're kind of in theory stripping
out the risk because you're buying 500
companies
so the s p index can be viewed as a
proxy for monetary inflation
and
the question of inflation is what's your
inflation rate well what do you need to
buy
if you're a consumer
then your inflation rate might be cpi if
you agree to buy what the federal
reserve tells you you should want
right and and the market basket of
things in the cpi is what the government
says you should want in your life but
they never included a picasso or a jet
or a yacht or a house in miami beach
in that market basket a step even
further than that is the number 14 uh
percent is very interesting because my
understanding is uh if you go back
obviously uh cpi used to represent a
cost of goods index so what is literally
the change of price of individual goods
year over year over year and that's how
inflation was measured now obviously we
have a cost of living index which is
what you're talking about in terms of
well here's the things that we think you
should want here's the general
weightings of these specific assets or
consumables inside of this basket and
then that's kind of our moving target
for this measurement of inflation but if
you were to go back um and look at the
cost of goods index based on how it used
to be calculated
for cpi and apply it to today's numbers
you get about 14
and so not only is the s p not only is
that monetary inflation but also that
cost of goods index based on the
original calculation of inflation is
around 14 as well which is uh you know
there's coincidences in life but it
seems to keep coming back to somewhere
in that kind of mid uh teen
number when we're trying to understand
what is that inflation isn't it
interesting you know the hedonic
adjustments kill you but
on the other hand
you know and and i say this oftentimes
inflation is a vector and what i mean is
you got to use you got to use
multi-dimensional arrays
and and linear algebra to even start
multi-n-dimensional linear algebra to
even start
to deal with the issue another way to
say it is you can calculate a different
inflation rate for any person in any
jurisdiction based upon their mix of
product services and assets they want to
acquire
and so common sense says a person that
wants to acquire a set of manufactured
goods and wants to watch streaming
youtube has a lower inflation rate than
someone that wants to buy picassos now
what if you want to be rich if you want
to be rich your inflation rate is very
high
because you have to acquire assets if
you want to be middle class your
inflation rate is different
so
back to why why i did what i did
if you're the ceo of a publicly traded
company your inflation rate is the cost
to capital
and the cost to cap because your
shareholders hold you to that cost of
capital if i go to a public a public
investor and i tell them my goal is two
percent
and they're saying well the s p is up 14
percent
then i'm undershooting their goal their
their index is is the s p index right so
so the inflation rate for an investor
is the index
now of course different investors have
different impact decisions if you go
back to the strategy if you're a fixed
income investor
you're you've got like a a sovereign you
know or corporate uh fixed income rate
you know you've got the junk bond index
you've got the corporate
you know investment grade index you've
got the sovereign debt index
you have capital structures in the world
that have different indexes someone that
wants to send their kids to an ivy
league school
and wants to have a house in the
hamptons
right they have a different index
someone
and someone that wants to be obscenely
wealthy has a different index right so
that's why you could everybody talking
past each other because
all
and of course if you keep changing the
indexes
the s p 500 index changes right they
rebalance it
the pci the pce indexes they get
rebalanced so so the indexes are
changing
and if you allow someone else to feed
you the index they want you to focus on
you can
you can see it right now right the
official inflation rate in canada is
four percent but the housing price is up
fifteen percent the official inflation
rate in the us is five percent but the
case shiller index is up 27
okay and uh
and uh of course
it all comes down to deciding what you
want in life now in the last 12 months
the s p is up 34 percent if you're
sitting on a 100 billion dollars worth
of cash
and you put it in the s p index you got
34 billion dollars back you have 134
billion right now
if you if you held it in conventional
treasuries you're short 34 billion
if you convince yourself that the
inflation rate was five percent or if
you convince yourself that you're you
could say look my treasury index is is
just the short dated sovereign debt
index and so as long as i'm beating the
20 basis points
i'm good
and you know and and and uh by the way
like
if i have a bunch of money sitting in a
bank my bankers come to me i've
literally had
bankers from the big wire houses they
came to me when i'm sitting on 100
million or 200 million in cash and they
go
you know
we can get you into one of our money
market funds that'll yield 22 basis
points
and that's much better than the nine
basis points and they're selling this to
me there are people in suits
that make a lot of money
and they're selling it to me and you
read the prospectus and the prospectus
is
they're gonna do something and they're
gonna charge you a 27 basis point fee to
generate 22 basis point yield to you
you're literally they're making more
money than you are you're giving 60
of the yield to someone in a suit that's
getting that's giving you a service to
get your five basis points more but
there are
there are people that convince
themselves
this is a good idea right and
we come back to that second it is a it's
an important truism in the market why is
it that everybody hasn't bought bitcoin
people ask that right all the bitcoiners
wonder why don't all these investors buy
bitcoin and the answer is because
there's trillions of dollars of capital
locked up in capital structures that are
chasing a different index
right there's trillions of dollars of
money sitting with people that think
that inflation is cpi
there's trillions of dollars sitting in
real estate funds and they're trying to
beat cpi if
i got rents and i'm raising them at the
cpi rate and i'm happy with it
there's trillions of dollars invested in
fixed income funds where they have to
beat the trunk bond index or beat the
corporate index or beat the sovereign
index and if they beat the sovereign
index
if i have if i have 20 billion dollars
and all i got to do is beat you know the
junk bond index or or i get paid then
i'm getting paid to invest 20 billion
dollars to get 50 basis points more
what happens to those people
let's say that inflation isn't 5.1 or
5.4 wherever it comes in on a monthly
basis now uh and we all agree it's
something that is higher but there's
disagreement on how much higher is it
six percent or is it 14
um in terms of uh the actual inflation
number what happens to all the people
who are using cpi as the benchmark do
they just succumb to the inflation over
time and continue to lose money until
they wake up or something else i think a
lot of people have a hybrid situation
like um for example
let's say i run a real estate trust or i
run a real estate company and i have
a hundred million dollars
a year worth of rental income
it's capped at cpi
does the leases are assigned 10 years 20
years 30 years duration five years
duration and then you've got
all the trade relationships like i can't
go to i can't go to the people that rent
my
building and tell them that the
inflation rate's 14
right i mean would you pay a 14 increase
in your rent here no no no so there's a
certain inertia in
in parts of the economy where they're
going to move up at cpi or they're going
to be flat or maybe they can do double
cpi but at the same time maybe you're
the person running that real estate
company you're thinking well i'm going
to take my cash flows and i'm going to
invest them in would you invest them in
a stock that you thought would go up at
cpi or would you invest them in the s p
index if you thought you would get cpi
not really
so what you have is you have people that
are sweeping their cash flows from an
operating business
that's low growth
and they're putting in the s p index
if you know they're looking for the
growth to come from the investment okay
the s p is up 34
how many companies in the world
generated 34 more cash flow or raised
their prices by 34
or grew their revenues 34 in the last 12
months
not many right 98
99
they're in a they're in a a fiat
operating system where
they're going to raise their prices or
generate cash flows at a rate slower
than
the rate of monetary inflation
but
those same people will turn around and
they'll buy bitcoin
or they'll buy property or that you may
buy property that you is going up faster
right
there's not a single commercial rent
there's not a single commercial lease i
think in the world where they raised the
price of the rent 27 in the last 12
months right
at least
i can't imagine if you had a lease no
one's got it capped at the case shiller
index
so on one hand residential property or
other types of property could actually
be accreting at a much higher rate while
your rents don't accrete at a higher
rate so
you're taking duration risk
so i
i guess the more important point is
there's a lot of capital when we think
about capital structure
it's like 500 trillion dollars to 900
trillion dollars of capital floating
around there it's locked up in
structures
some of it is in currencies and and it
can move rapidly some of it is invested
in companies that can't
right move rapidly some of it is tied up
in in uh equity some of it is tied up in
in debt
some of it's tied up in a trust i have a
trust my trust gave 10 million dollars
to a financial
advisor or or to a company whose
strategy is investing in
mid-duration corporate debt and every
year i review their performance versus
their index and over the course of a
decade i might start to
shift small amounts out
but i think that the capital is
structured in such a way there's enough
inertia in the system it could take
30 years
yeah for the for the capital to get
reallocated right like we're we're
waging a war on the 60 40 portfolio
right
how long will it take before people
allocate that as 65 35 or 70 30. right
it takes a long time there are people
still invested in gold you and i joke
about that
gold's been failing for 12 years or
something like that right gold's the
same price as it was when bitcoin was
invented and yet
an aggressive move would be a macro
investor allocating from 50
gold to 45
gold and 5 bitcoin and that's a bit
that's a year's work yeah let me ask
this question um retail investors or
individuals i think uh over the last 12
years or so um took bitcoin and as a
generalized group it went from a
contrarian idea or contrarian trade to a
consensus trade there's now you know 100
plus million people around the world
that have decided hey this is good
enough for me to go ahead and store some
of my value uh or economic wealth here
um and so you can argue that that
contrarianism became more of a consensus
we now over the last maybe 18 months
have seen in the financial or
institutional uh finance world more
people jumping into the game and so
definitely some shift from pure
contrarianism to now a little bit more
of a consensus everyone has to have some
sort of bitcoin strategy you can't
simply just say oh it's just for drug
dealers it's just for criminals you at
least have to have had a conversation
now because fidelity paul tudor jones
stanley druckenmiller many others have
all now started to participate
what does it take for public companies
where i basically break down there's two
groups right there's yourself tesla and
square as the three major publicly
traded businesses that are multi-billion
dollar companies that have pursued a
treasury strategy that includes bitcoin
and then there are all of the publicly
traded crypto native companies whether
they're miners whether places like
coinbase etc
it's still contrarian in the public
markets to have bitcoin on your balance
sheet what does it take to get the shift
that we've seen in those other two
cohorts to now get it to a consensus
type uh you know movement or idea
i mean i think there's some
you could check off catalyst
that are impediments that will become
accelerators
um
first of all uh regulatory clarity
right uh
if you're hearing if you're seeing
support for
let's start with the most basic issue is
bitcoin an asset or a currency
okay
the word cryptocurrency has is a very
politically charged world word because
if bitcoin was a currency it's an
opposition to the us dollar okay
and if it's an asset it's an opposition
to gold
okay so um just resolving the fact it's
a digital asset not a digital currency
most people's how many public uh
speakers how many how many well-regarded
investors have made negative comments
about bitcoin over the past 12 months
because they're mistaken they mistakenly
think it's a currency and they think
they're sticking up for the dollar right
many
like i prefer the dollar so if you
understand it's a digital asset
a a scarce store of value
speculative digital asset that's how
politically correct people would refer
to it
right and
anybody else would say it's just it's
just a digital asset or a store of value
asset the first uh the first impediment
is just understanding that and educating
the market that it's a digital asset i
think the second impediment is
getting over the issue of uh is it a
threat
to the powers that being will be banned
so first what is it it's an asset second
will it be banned okay well no we're not
going to ban cryptocurrency we're not
going to ban bitcoin it's going to be
around here so those two check boxes are
huge
i think the third uh
check box is can i actually buy it via
my existing bank every publicly traded
company's been doing business with
probably the same bank for 30 years pomp
some have been doing this with the same
bank for 50 years
some for 100 years
okay if you trace it to to have adopted
a new banking relationship is not a one
in a decade thing but public companies
don't change in a decade right
so
if i could if i could buy this directly
through bank of america or jpmorgan or
city group etc i think that makes a big
difference if i have to go
to a you know
an institutional-grade bitcoin exchange
that's a one-year exercise in due
diligence
right friction to doing it
there's two issues right one is
is before you give a billion dollars
to a counterparty
you know you have to you have to inspect
their accountants their legal teams
their licensing their executive team
would you give a billion dollars to a
private company
that's new right it's like that's a huge
hurdle um and the second is they're not
fdic insured right they're not the
the in primitive being backed by the us
government means that you know in a
liquidity crisis the federal reserve
gives you 10 billion dollars or a
hundred billion dollars how much money
did you need right
and that's what the big uh the big
license banks have and you know the last
holdout that
wasn't doing that was goldman sachs and
the great financial crisis they broke
down and they became a bank
right and um
it matters so if you want to move huge
sums of capital
right at the point that uh some of the
the major banks handle the asset that
makes a big difference
because uh it checks a lot of boxes and
people are pretty conservative about
that
i think the
the next hurdle is uh accounting
um
explain what the accounts problem is
because this i don't think a lot of
people understand how big of a problem
this is
um
it's a source of massive inertia because
every publicly traded company is running
on gap accounting and so we're
publishing our gaap uh balance sheet and
our p l every quarter
and um investors are reading the p l and
the whole point of gap accounting is
in in theory i ought to be able at a
glance in 30 seconds look at your
balance sheet and know how much capital
you have and in 15 seconds look at your
p l and know whether or not the business
is well run
and when the gap accounting aligns
with the underlying
business then you can do that but when
it gets out of alignment then you have
to adjust it with pro forma accounting
non-gaap accounting or adjusted
accounting and when you get to adjusted
accounting
it goes from being a 30-second
inspection to a 30-minute
thing and you know how difficult it is
to communicate a 30-minute concept to
the world very very challenging
so the
the issue right now
and the issue when we got into bitcoin
is
is no publicly traded company held any
material bitcoin so
so uh the accounting treatment was
probably appropriately conservative the
most conservative accounting treatment
you could imagine is indefinite and
tangible
and what indefinite intangible
accounting means is
you buy something
you you test it against the market
continually
you take the lowest bid
and you mark the value of the asset down
to the lowest bid at any point in the
history of your ownership
and
you treat that not as an investment
but you treat that as a loss in the core
business the operating business
so
if you have a business that makes 100
million a year
and it's run perfectly
you know with a perfect pegged 20
operating margin
right uh if you buy bitcoin and bitcoin
trades down for one hour and trades back
up again you might have a hundred
million dollar operating loss
and then you would be showing the
business made no money this year on a
gap basis so now you're an outside
investor and you're staring and saying
what happened to the software business
it looks like it the operation got
wrecked it's
if i made a million decisions poorly
you know i probably couldn't i couldn't
go from 100 million in cash flow to zero
right or if i did it'd be challenging
but or on a saturday night someone could
flash crash something and you would have
a 100 million dollar loss showing on the
operating statement
so indefinite intangible means you'd
take the volatility as an operating loss
on your p l
and you take the theoretical
worst case the theoretical worst case
would be
i buy bitcoin and i wait for the lowest
price ever and i sell it all okay
that you take the theoretical worst case
and you represent that as the as the uh
status
so when you print your quarterly results
you print your annual results
you want a simple example you buy a
billion of bitcoin it trades down to 500
million
then it
increases to a billion then increases by
a factor of 10 to 10 billion
if that's the fact pattern when you
close your books under indefinite
intangible
your books say you have 500 million
dollars of assets
and it says that you lost 500 million
dollars in the in the operating business
and the money's gone that's what gap
accounting says
in actuality you might have a statement
that says you have ten billion dollars
of assets and it looks to the uh to the
casual observer like you generated a
nine billion dollar investment gain
so you can now how do you fix it
pro forma adjusted accounting you have
to create a schedule a reconciliation
but but um
now what have you done you've just made
uh the uh
first of all you've made the uh the
investor's job
100 times harder
and investors got to read all the pro
formas think about it and figure and
then they've got to reverse it out and
figure out what really happened in the
rest of the business
right and then they've got to figure out
what's your balance sheet really look
like and then
the second problem you have
is
your um your statements become
non-comparable over time like for
example
i can't
if i look at my balance sheet on a gap
basis
today versus a year ago
right bitcoin could go up by a factor of
100 the balance sheet doesn't change so
when you're comparing quarter versus
quarter there's no information there
because you're suppressing it right yeah
and then if two companies
have bitcoin one company has a hundred
thousand coin and one company has ten
thousand coin and bitcoin goes up by a
factor of ten
neither company shows an investment gain
neither company shows a balance sheet
adjustment and so how do you compare one
company to the other company
if you're trying to make a rational
investment decision so things become
non-comparable across
securities and they become
non-comparable across time
and
you're invited as an investor to create
your own
set of pro-forma systems to compare
yourself which is like 1000 times harder
so
that's an impediment uh for a public
company or for a company that relies
upon gaap accounting but here's where
it's really an impediment like why can
microstrategy do it
well because we rotated our shareholder
base to be long bitcoin and because
fortunately enough
uh we were we were able to build a
substantial bitcoin position so now if
you know that microstrategy has a
hundred and
[Music]
you know fourteen thousand
114 000 bitcoin yeah if i have 114 000
bitcoin and i you know
114 042 bitcoin all you have to know
about microstrategy is take 114 000 and
you multiply by the price and you know
that we've got that much
but let's say that you were google
or you were apple or you were facebook
well you've got all these other
businesses or amazon and now you're
trying to decompose the businesses
and uh if they buy a big bitcoin
position
then uh what looks like a pristine p l
that every everybody debates you know as
apple's gross margin going to be 38 or
38.5 percent this quarter and that's a
big deal right
i mean their people take victory laps on
getting within one percent of the gross
margin
well your gross margins would totally
get all your money get blown out of the
water from the volatility the accounting
volatility of the bitcoin
so how do we solve it
what is the change that needs to be made
where you would say okay the system we
have right now is a issue and it's an
impediment
if we move to x that's the solution in
your opinion
yeah well um
so there
i joke with people right like you'll be
better off buying baseball cards or or
arts or just about anything than buying
bitcoin from accounting point of view
because if you were to buy
if i went and bought sculpture
or you know
some random anything
normally the test would be like once a
year
you check to see if the asset's been
impaired
but checking to see if an asset's
impaired occasionally
is much better than checking to see if
the assets impaired every minute of the
day right so
so uh there are different types of
accounting treatments but
if you were to buy a billion dollars
worth of um a security like an etf
like one immediate fix is you buy a
billion dollars worth of a bitcoin etf
it's not proper anymore it's a security
if you're owning a security generally
accounting says you value securities
based on fair fair market value or fair
value accounting so that means that
that um if it doubles you would show an
investment gain this is the warren
buffett's accounting for coca-cola stock
or for apple right
so very fair value accounting is applied
to securities
fair value accounting is applied to
certain other things if the accounting
goes from indefinite and tangible to
fair value
in that case then you would be showing
the 10 billion dollars of bitcoin as an
asset on your balance sheet and then you
would show the gain or loss as an
investment what they call below the line
adjustment
like on a quarter where it's up 2
billion you would have a 2 billion
investment gain and a quarter where it's
down 500 million you have a 500 million
dollar investment loss
and that's that provides more clarity
it's kind of a benefit to investors
because an investor can they can
separate
the gain in the loss from investment
activity from the gain and the loss from
operating activity
right and that helps you to figure out
is is the core business healthy and you
if warren buffett prints like three
dollars a share or some large amount of
eps
i want to decompose it into how much of
it was from the stock portfolio versus
how much of it was from the operating
businesses
right and
and then i can extrapolate out
rationally
so ultimately i think fair value
accounting is the solution to allow
public companies to hold
the hold this in large quantity
this is why say even a tesla or square
would buy not a hundred percent of their
balance sheet or fifty percent but five
percent yeah
if it's five percent or one percent or
two percent it's not going to be
material
to the rest of the p l and the rest of
the balance sheet treatment when it
becomes 50
the volatility from the accounting
treatment will optically impair
transparency against the p l and the
rest
so when i look at the public companies
right now let's put aside the kind of
bitcoin or crypto native companies the
miners and um uh
coinbase etc
there's basically three publicly traded
ceos that uh are orange pilled right
yourself jack dorsey elon musk those
seem to be the ones who
have
purchased bitcoin who have talked about
it publicly
who
appear to understand the ethos of it and
kind of why it's important for their
businesses
is this something where
we are literally going to see one by one
by one each individual ceo is going to
have to get orange peeled and eventually
uh make this decision or is there some
milestone or like inflection point where
you say when x occurs we will then see
you know on a quarter by quarter basis
tens of publicly traded companies or
hundreds of publicly traded companies
all going ahead and doing this okay well
first i would say it's not just the
three there's
there's probably three dozen but every
bitcoin miner is holding bitcoin on his
balance sheet
and one of the major things one of the
catalysts that's taken place in the last
12 months is all the bitcoin miners
coming public and all of the miners that
were public on
international stock exchanges shifting
over to the nasdaq and the new york
stock exchange right
marathon and riot and actually if you
look at it right now marathon has got a
bitcoin exposure
i
i wonder when silvergate
bank will right or how that'll work but
silvergate's obviously a bitcoin company
coinbase has got bitcoin on its balance
sheet
right you've got bitfarms hut eight
you've got
sphere you've got bit digital you've got
galaxy you know you've got well there's
a bunch of businesses that come out of
the industry and i think we're going to
see more and more go public so let's say
that that number doubles or triples of
like the publicly traded companies that
come out of the bitcoin and crypto
industry because you're just going to
get a bunch of startups that continue to
grow and eventually go public whether
it's direct listings ipos or spax that
number will just grow and i think
there's a dozen other companies that are
public that are holding it in their
treasury at a a smaller amount so
so what did the catalyst
i mean clearly
one thing that's already happening right
is the regulatory clarity that's coming
um the more clarity if the regulators uh
move forward and they clarify the
treatment of uh stable coins and
security tokens
and defy exchanges
i you know i feel like the
the connection of bitcoin to crypto
has been holding it back
right because because stable coin
regulation is unclear secure many
cryptos or security tokens that's uh
that's holding us back the exchanges
that are trading bitcoin while they're
trading security tokens right the
connection of bitcoin to shib or
dogecoin
right this this holds back um
a public entity from wanting to get into
that space i mean in fact it's it's
really
the express concern that the sec has
about uh approving a bitcoin spot etf
right which is they're concerned about
the markets
where uh bitcoin is trading right and
they're concerned probably about
what's what's bitcoin volatility coming
from it's coming from the cross
collateralization of of crypto markets
with high leverage
trading it off hours
right against thin liquidity pools of
other security tokens
right and so
as to ask that clarity comes with regard
to the entire crypto ecosystem
it's it's going uh to decrease
volatility and it's going to increase
confidence
of large public investors and large
public companies that'll be part i think
as if we get clarity from fasb
or or any kind of improvement in the
accounting situation
uh that's a that's a plus and there's i
mean there's a groundswell of interest
right there are 515 letters sent to
fazbey on the subject and
and there was a lot of commentary from
regulators from you know we've got
congressmen we've got senators
we've got uh auditors we've got big
institutional investors we've got big
publicly traded companies and they're
all opinining on the issue so and i have
yet to see anybody
i haven't seen any articulation by
anyone suggesting that the current
accounting treatment
is beneficial yeah
so it's it's it's broad-based consensus
that it's time to take a look at this
again so i think that accounting is
important i think that you know we just
see the barriers with the banks getting
knocked down right
like at the point that
you saw the commentary by the chair of
the fdic
where she said we're looking for ways to
allow banks to hold bitcoin on their
balance sheets
right if uh if fd ic
it used to be we dreamed our dream was
one day
big banks
may actually own bitcoin
you know what if all the big banks own
bitcoin but now i think we flipped to
the
to another observation and this is a
this is an interesting one in that
stable coin
working group
paper that was released last week
not only did they say it's okay for fdic
approved banks to hold stable coins they
actually said it's required to be an
fdic insured bank to hold a stable coin
okay so we're we're actually growing up
as a crypto industry we're going from
unlicensed
non-institutional grade corporations
that are primarily entrepreneurial and
fast-moving
to licensed institutional
regulated entities
and
if you look at that isn't the conclusion
that the next step i see as a green
light jp morgan
citigroup bank of america are going to
issue a trillion dollars worth of stable
coins i mean it's an invitation like
it's a green light
to every single
bank in the world right if you're if
you're silver gate or you know
anybody that's in the crypto industry
now
right this is this is kind of um
a message
i don't think it's that much longer
right
if
you can hold a stable coin as a digital
asset it's not that much longer behold
before you hold bitcoin as a digital
asset
and if if the fdic is saying we need to
find a way for banks to be able to hold
this
and if the president's working group is
saying you need to be a bank in order to
hold this the stable coin
then um
i think that sometime in the next 12
months
we actually start to see large banks
getting in the business is this good or
bad the like financialization of bitcoin
let's talk about and then there's
obviously all of these other
technologies and assets but i think that
there's a group that
would argue
the more that the asset becomes
financialized the more that it gets
not just accepted by the licensed
organizations but you see
legislation or directives that say
you have to be fdic insured in order to
interface with this stuff
they look at that as negative there's
other people who look at it as a
positive so how do you think about the
pros and cons of what i'll just call
like the financialization of what were
assets that you know many people were
attracted to in the beginning because
they weren't part of uh the existing
system
bitcoin is decentralized and it's an
asset and it's already gone to 200
million places
and you might not like the people that
own it right don't they call it the
money of enemies
yeah right the point is bitcoin's going
to people who have politics that you
disagree with
right
it's almost certain so it's spreading at
such a rate
it's like fire and it's like electricity
or mathematics and you can have an
opinion
do you think it's good or bad for banks
to have mathematics
it's like
we're the only ones with math is it good
or bad for people to be able to read and
write
it used to you know there was a concern
that we shouldn't let everybody read and
write it's just basic technology it's
spreading as fast as it can spread the
reason it's superior to gold is because
i can snap my fingers and i can withdraw
a billion dollars of bitcoin from the
bank in five minutes correct okay and
the thing that's going to maintain its
integrity
is the fact that
that you can
uh you can shift counterparties you can
move
if you can move 10 billion dollars of an
asset out of a jurisdiction i can move
it out of miami i can move it out of a
bank i can move it out of a country i
can move it out of a system
it's always going to have more integrity
than the alternative
so
coming back to this it's like
okay
are you comfortable there are a lot of
people that don't think you should have
a software wallet on an iphone you
should have a hardware wallet
right there are a lot of people that
think that that um it's better if if
what if i don't want your family to have
it because i don't like somebody in your
family right what if i don't want your
small company you have a private company
do you own some bitcoin well you know
did you sell out now there's a company
that's got other corporate interests
that has some bitcoin
a lot of people don't want a public
company to have it why well public
companies have shareholders
yeah well
i don't want a country to have it right
i mean a lot of people that are
concerned that el salvador uses bitcoin
well it might get hijacked by the
politicians
what if turkey actually starts buying
bitcoin do i like it do i not like it
the point is it doesn't matter what you
think right
it's not it's like you sitting and
saying i'm really angry that someone
else is using arithmetic other than me
right
it's spreading like wildfire it seems to
me
that the world's a better place if
people have monetary integrity than if
they don't have monetary integrity
i agree right
right um and in this particular case is
is this good
yeah of course it's good
right why is it good
it's good because
because um
what we want to do is fix everything
not destroy everything right
if you want to fix the bank
then
they replace their bonds with bitcoin
and the capital structure of the bank is
better if you want do you want to fix
every publicly traded company in the
world do you want to fix the balance
sheet of apple and google and facebook
and amazon
if i tell you that they have to do the
deal through an fdic insured bank
then you either can fix them
right there a lot of people don't want
to fix them they don't want they don't
want apple or google or facebook to fix
their balance sheet they don't want them
to fix their product but
but on the other hand i'm an optimist
what do i think i think eight billion
people should be
uh using bitcoin as a digital asset now
there's two ways to do it the easy way
and the hard way the hard way is topple
every government in the universe destroy
every technology company and create my
own hardware wallet and my own
decentralized
well let's rip back to the network
destroy every big tech platform destroy
every big company and somehow let's
build something totally new that's the
hard way
seems pretty stressful to me what's the
easy way
the easy way is
all the big banks start issuing stable
coin a token called the us dollar right
a u.s dollar stable coin and we go from
130 billion dollars in stable coins to a
trillion dollars of stable coins to 10
trillion dollars of stable coins to 100
trillion dollars of
usd
and then 8 billion people
have a have an iphone or an android
phone with a with a wallet and they do
10 20 50 transactions a day
at the speed of light
on the lightning network
on the lightning network and if they and
that's the best right a decentralized
non-custodial network moving at the
speed of light for free next best
is they move these things around on the
android or the imessage or the whatsapp
or the facebook or layer 2 or layer 3
application right that's second best and
they do it without toppling every
government on earth right like i i can't
there's 130 currencies that are floating
right now
130. how many do we need
well we we certainly could get by the
next step with 12 right the cny is not
going away and the usd is unless you
wish to topple
the government of china and the
government of the us and the governments
of the western world which i don't think
you want to do right you got bigger
problems if you did right like security
and safety and food
chaos and it would be a very very
painful situation for everyone yeah
right like so so if you if you look at
in
at an optimistic view let's just
actually make the world a better place
and a win-win for everybody so your
thought process is uh this asset which
has that monetary integrity that you're
talking about it's fully transparent
it's a in many cases you can look at it
as an automated central bank nobody
controls it it just sits there
programmatically executing what the code
says for it to do
that will serve as a global store of
value other people will then choose to
take their fiat currencies and upgrade
the technology doesn't necessarily
change their monetary policy but they
can then go ahead and digitize or
tokenize the dollar uh uh the euro the
end juan whatever currency and then they
would basically use the bitcoin network
payment rails to have those uh assets
fly around the world however people
chose but ultimately people would go
back to and settle in uh bitcoin as that
global store of value
partially but it's a it's a more
elaborate
idea which is
my idea is we incrementally upgrade
everything everywhere for everybody in
the most peaceful
least painful
least jarring way right so the inc
the incremental upgrade means
means uh
we deploy
to 8 billion people
to everybody on the planet we deploy
digital wallets and the wallet you have
a set of currencies and a set of assets
and in that wallet in argentina you've
got your peso and you've got your dollar
as currencies
if you want to hold something for a day
you hold a peso if you want to hold it
for a month you hold a dollar if you
want to hold it for a lifetime you hold
bitcoin right you've got digital assets
bitcoin is the strongest digital asset
um is it the only asset
no because you've got a company there
are buildings there's apple i still like
google i want my youtube i like netflix
right we need domino's pizza we need
bitcoin pizza someone's got to
manufacture the cameras that are staring
us right now got a microphone we can't
just have one asset we have multiple
assets we have multiple currencies
will all currencies survive no
the weak ones the ones that are truly
defective will go away 66 countries are
dollarized
there's 180 countries in the world how
many currencies do we really need
right we
right now it's china and the usd right
you might actually collapse down to two
but more likely you'll have the yen and
you'll have the euro and you'll have the
dollar
is there any currency in africa that you
really want to hold more than the dollar
if you had the freedom of choice
not really
what will you do though you need
you you need the local currency for
local payments right if there's a strong
local government you need the local
currency to pay your tax bills because
it's mandated by law you need the global
the global currency
and it's called the us the global
reserve digital currency the global
reserve currency you need that as a
medium of exchange if you want to buy
something in argentina from someone in
brazil or you want to buy something in
africa from someone in venezuela you're
probably going to swap dollars right why
because there's a hundred million
companies pomp
that have invested 30 years to create
accounting systems and point-of-sale
systems to process billions and billions
of transactions in those currencies
like my company does it i
i can actually swap my balance sheet to
bitcoin using three people and i can do
that in a matter of weeks
swapping all of my
vendor payments all of my payroll and
all of my receivables into bitcoin
that would be a billion times harder
okay
and it's not worth a billion times more
stress and effort it's not it's just not
worth it right it's
an inflationary environment money
decomposes into a currency layer which
is losing value slow hopefully slowly
if your currency lost value one percent
a month but your asset gained value at
15 20 percent a year
that's stable
now
do we need to replace it
not this decade right i'm not going to
speculate 30 40 50 years out but i
rather kind of feel like
a a more nuanced idea
here's a nuanced idea
i want to build the 21st century economy
on a strong foundation of integrity and
trust and thermodynamic soundness and
energy pure energy
so
that means the balance sheet the
foundation of every institution
should be built on bitcoin
but
every institution has its own derivative
its own security from bitcoin so when
you create your company if you want to
take your company public
you should be able to issue stocks and
stock options backed by bitcoin i'm not
denying that
if turkey goes and they buys billions of
dollars of bitcoin they can keep the
currency they would be backing the
currency with
with a hard asset
how many institutions are there
in the world that need some control like
like maybe uh if i said to you can't
issue stock in a company is that good
for the economy
not really
if i said no country can print its own
currency
is that good
probably not really
right um because the politicians need
some power over the currency
right i mean unless you come up with a
way to generate all the food and all the
products that we need without companies
and without countries like when you
figure that out that's like a utopian
idea then maybe you can live with
bitcoin only and
and the like
but in the meantime which is like let's
just focus on the next decade
because there's no point in solving this
problem after the year 2030 right yeah
right focus in the next decade the next
decade it works like this
all the big banks issue usd stable coins
what happens the us dollar replaces all
the weak currencies and it grows in
strength right the u.s dollar can become
the daily currency of six billion people
and it has been doing that for some time
you mentioned the dollarized country
right now
right now analog dollars and the 20th
century banking system is the reserve
currency of the world but it's an awful
inefficient system right yeah how do you
send a hundred dollars to someone on
saturday afternoon if they live in
africa if you live in south america
how send someone to a friend of yours in
paris
on a tuesday i dare you right so the
point right now is the u.s dollar is the
world's reserve currency but it's
running on on 20th century rails
so
the u.s dollar should evolve to run on
crypto rails it should run on you know
we can debate right lightning rails
what's up rails
you know any other crypto right
interesting question but what what we
can't debate
which is 100 certain is everybody wants
to be able to move the money at the
speed of light and program it on a
computer chip on a saturday afternoon
that's that
sometimes we get in this uh in this
confrontational state where people think
well it's bitcoin versus the fed or
bitcoin versus the dollar
it's not right we can all win
right it's a win-win here it's in the
best interest of the dollar to move at
the speed of light and be programmable
and there's a hundred million businesses
that want to do business in the dollar
and
i am the controlling shareholder of
microstrategy i found the company i mean
there aren't that many ceos that have
more power than me if i walked into a
room and i ordered
everybody in my finance team to convert
over all the accounting systems
and stop and sell everything and and
satoshi's
and pay everybody in satoshis
you know
you understand that uh if everybody
didn't quit on the spot
it would be a decade and a billion
dollars of work
and it wouldn't work and by the time i
finished the billion dollars of work the
company operation would go to zero
right it's literally a death sentence
for a big institution to attempt to
convert over its um its mediums of
exchange and its accounting systems for
for routine transaction so so right now
really the value is to get bitcoin onto
the balance sheet as a store value
protect shareholder value that's sitting
there continue to operate your
businesses and you know
my understanding of what microstrategy
is doing is you basically have uh
articulated and highlighted two separate
strategies we have a software business
that we're going to continue to try to
grow uh drive cash flow and serve our
customers from a business intelligence
standpoint and then we have a treasury
strategy which is uh we're going to use
bitcoin to protect our purchasing power
and our assets that are actually sitting
on the balance sheet and those two
strategies combined make up the business
uh and you know obviously the market has
found it incredibly attractive given uh
what the stock price has done over the
last year or so
well
if your apple computer
right you've got
you've got two strategies you can pursue
to get in the digital economy one
strategy is you just buy 50 billion
dollars of bitcoin
and three people can do it
and if the three people did it then your
stock becomes a bitcoin derivative apple
stock becomes a bitcoin derivative and
if bitcoin moves up at 100 a year right
you're generating 50 billion dollars a
year of shareholder value
three people 50 billion shareholder
value right it's very simple strategy
the harder strategy
is you start building uh bitcoin
protocol
or lightning protocol
into all your other products you can
build it into the iphone you can build
it in the icloud you can you know you
can build it into all of your other
services
you know and and uh they all have merit
and that's an operating strategy and at
that at some point that starts to um
that starts to uh correlate your
revenues
to the growth of of the digital asset
economy and the growth of bitcoin
so
and and all that both of those are
rational
what's not rational
what's not rational
is um
is to require that all your customers
pay you in bitcoin
and stop taking dollars right right you
can control what you do with your
balance sheet right and you can control
what your strategy is but implementing
it on your customers or to rewire all
your
all your backend accounting systems so
and it's unnecessary right it's it's not
the right way so
like coming back to
to my view of the world i mean i i think
my view of the world is
we want to find the path of least
resistance to to fix everything and that
means that means uh
looking at every single part of the
economy every country will be better if
they had some bitcoin
cities can
can be improved if they buy bitcoin if a
city buys bitcoin and they issue bonds
the bond becomes a bitcoin back bond
right it becomes a derivative of bitcoin
so i'm not against bonds right i'm not
the guy saying we shouldn't have bonds
we should have bonds right if the junk
bond index is four percent and you can
issue a bitcoin back bond at six percent
it's good for the people that have
trillions of dollars locked up in bonds
it's good for bitcoin it's good for
everybody in the middle
right we could say we can take the
orthodox draconian view which is bond
should go away and bitcoin should
replace them overnight but it's not it's
not possible but it's not even a better
view right yeah a better view is
you take your bank and you start
handling
bitcoin and you take your mobile app and
you build lightning into the mobile app
and you take your company and
and uh and you buy it and
you buy bitcoin and the reason i don't
really think it's a threat
to the bitcoin ethos is because
ultimately
none of these people can control bitcoin
it's like people worry like
so i have seven billion dollars or eight
billion dollars of bitcoin i don't have
any more power
anybody else
right and and in fact
the only sentiment that's grown in my
mind as my bitcoin position has grown is
i don't want anybody to change it like
don't mess it up
right so i think that is i'm not
threatened if a government buys bitcoin
it wouldn't be bad for bitcoin right i'm
not threatened if a company buys it if a
bank buys it
yeah and here i guess there is one
there's one point worth making
if you're um
if your portfolio is 100 bitcoin
you don't have any conflicts of interest
the you know the debate of whether or
not people use square cash app paypal
robin hood coinbase binance or buy the
etf or buy it through fidelity or nida
doesn't really matter to you
right it doesn't matter to you whether
they buy microstrategy stock to get
bitcoin exposed doesn't matter to you
right you're just holding the underlying
asset
if you decide that you want to get in
the business of selling hardware wallets
or if you run an exchange or if you
provide advice and if
now you have a conflict of interest so
now you're you're a bitcoin entrepreneur
and
maybe
like
if you're issuing if you're tether and
you're issuing stable coins
you don't want jp morgan to issue stable
coins
it's a conflict of interest right
competition right i mean if the feds say
you have to get an fdic license now you
got to jump through a hurdle now you
need general counsels you need to
actually pay lawyers you have to do
stuff right you have to have nexus you
have to have insurance it's harder so
so there are a lot of things that are
happening in the economy
they're good for bitcoin they're just
not good for every entrepreneur in the
crypto ecosystem
and there is a conflict of interest and
and that's why like people ask me well
are you going to get into other things
are you going to are you going to build
software
well that's conflict of interest you
know
are you gonna go into bitcoin mining
that's a conflict of interest are you
gonna you know invest with a
counterparty's conflict of interest
right so you can do that but those are
businesses
and they have investment risk
and you have competition and you can
fail or succeed and the truth of the
matter is
is it good for bitcoin
if jp morgan goldman sachs and bank of
america issue 10 trillion dollars of usd
stable coins and start handling bitcoin
and selling it to all their
institutional investors
yeah it's good for bitcoin bitcoin's
going to million dollars a coin then 10
million dollars a coin
and all the people that believed in
bitcoins for the last decade are going
to have the financial wherewithal to
create their own
companies to do whatever they want right
and and and
to express their sentiment
it's just not good for the entrepreneurs
to compete against the mega caps so let
me ask this question uh we recently have
seen a bunch of politicians all start to
pay attention in various ways so we've
got on one side um in the united states
most politicians uh started off abrasive
so you know without naming any of them
uh there's a number that we're very
concerned about bitcoin uh if you go
back a couple of years we then saw uh
obviously china go ahead and ban miners
and take a pretty abrasive uh step there
but over the last let's call it i don't
know eight months seven months uh we've
seen el salvador go ahead and make
bitcoin legal tender they seem to not
only be supporting it as legal tender
they also are onboarding people via
their this uh app that they've built and
also this atm network that they've built
they're mining bitcoin and kind of
really trying to plug their country if
you will into the bitcoin network and
then just recently over the last week or
two we've seen multiple politicians all
at the local level start to become much
more uh friendly or embracing of bitcoin
so you've got obviously the mayor in
miami who has been a very kind of pro
bitcoin for a while you've got eric
adams who's the new mayor of new york
city he now leaning in saying he's going
to take some of his paychecks in bitcoin
and some of the stuff should be taught
in schools et cetera we've also got two
kind of smaller mayors one in tennessee
and one in i think it's tampa bay uh in
florida all kind of leaning into this
how do you look at the intersection of
bitcoin and politicians and it's just
this just a continuation of like bitcoin
is good for business and so if it's good
for corporations then it's going to be
good for the politicians as well or how
do you read that situation
i think that um
one of the great advantages of bitcoin
is
is
it's money of the people it's money for
the people
and um
the combination of the fact that it's
permissionless and it's open
nobody controls it means everyone
everyone can adopt it everyone can
engage in it and the proof-of-work
network
means that you have
a large business
in bitcoin mining and what is bitcoin
mining bitcoin mining is like this it's
like your skin it's like it's
it's the first line of defense of your
immune system right it's what uh makes
you healthy
the bitcoin mining industry is a 22
billion dollar a year industry right now
that means that the protocol is creating
a 22 billion dollar subsidy
for
bitcoin entrepreneurs to go out into the
world and find supportive political
jurisdictions
22 billion dollars
and um
per year so when you think about that
that means that
the miners themselves they ha they have
to raise capital
but that but um you see the bitcoin
miners are ripping today in the market
right all their stocks are up yes and
they've been very successful you can
take a bitcoin miner public
you're not going to take a proof of
stake validator public right one of the
big
differentiators is
is the miners the miners
have to have to use energy and
technology but the miners are also
recruiting political capital to the
network and so
i
i think that uh
what you're seeing here is
is um lots of jurisdictions can see the
benefit of bitcoin either
as sound money
right
all the holders are political
constituency
and i i guess we're going to get close
to the point where we're going to flip
50 percent of the electorate right
there's going to be a bitcoiner in
congress there already are there's going
to be bitcoiners in the senate they
already are and eventually a bitcoiner
will be president it's not necessarily
because they're going to run on just a
bitcoin only ticket but they're going to
have grown up they're going to have held
the asset and they're going to become
the president of the united states and
hold bitcoin right
it's the most part bitcoin
bitcoin's the greatest brand in the
history of the world
first ch first observation it's the
greatest brand in the history of the
world what's brand value brand value is
monetary premium
right
the monetary premium of bitcoin is 1.2
trillion dollars right now name another
brand that's worth 1.2 trillion dollars
right so it's the greatest brand in the
world it's the greatest monetary asset
in the world i mean i'm not counting the
dollar because the dollar is a
inflationary asset it's not an
investment if you pick an asset that you
could reasonably expect to protect you
against inflation
bitcoin becomes the most popular one
other you know other than just like
random real estate right just owning
land i guess land was
maybe the most popular one and bitcoin
is is that digital property
so
how do i buy all these other things in
africa or asia or anywhere
right it's a very egalitarian asset and
that makes it politically
uh advantageous right i mean
how is it not what politician would say
i don't want you to own your own house
and i don't want you to have economic
freedom right
right i mean so i think that the left
and the right can both agree on that
it's pretty clear it's high velocity
money
the higher velocity than anything but
it's high velocity asset
it's a bank in cyberspace but it's a
franchise bank so anybody in on earth in
any jurisdiction can create their own
franchise of the bank and
what that means right packs full or you
know fill in the blank every crypto
exchange in every country on earth when
they're selling you bitcoin or
exchanging bitcoin they're in essence
creating
you know
uh a franchise bank of bitcoin where
they're marketing it so so bitcoin is
spreading
through
two
incredibly powerful franchises
the bitcoin exchangers
who are the bitcoin banks if you will
and it's open and permissionless right
so there's no you don't have to get a
license from the fdic to have a bank in
egypt that deals in bitcoin
uh and then it's spreading through the
bitcoin miners they're the security
providers so the security the network
operators and the and the bankers
are spreading like wildfire everywhere
and
who's an example well square cash app
right i mean that's an example of a
bitcoin bank paypal is a bitcoin bank
coinbase is a bitcoin bank binance is a
bitcoin bank
right
and uh and
when you look at marathon and riot and
all these bitcoin miners
they're the other side of the network so
i think that it's inevitable
that more and more politicians uh begin
to support the network
not everyone will
but
but um you know the game theory of it is
such that
the more hostile one regime is the more
lucrative it is for another regime right
it was a benefit to the united states
when china banned the bitcoin right
cracking down on bitcoin mining
was a gift handed to the west and i've
you know i've said it before i think
it's worth a trillion dollars
right and uh you can see it in the hash
rate statistics
um i
but at some point
it's
it's so
bitcoin mining is the most lucrative use
of energy in the world
oh that's hands down in the world very
provable and very verifiable in the
world and it's it's the best use of
intermittent energy and the best use of
sustainable energy
and so
when you look at it that way you know
you're thinking well
shouldn't we expect an avalanche more of
political support
and the answer is yes and and why is it
why is it um
stable it's stable because the bitcoin
miner is gonna and the bitcoin holders
are going to go wherever the politicians
support them and they're going to bring
their capital and they're going to pay
taxes
large sums of taxes so
the right way to think about bitcoin is
bitcoin's creating an opportunity
it's an opportunity for your family to
save money for a hundred years it's an
opportunity to fix your company
microstrategy stock is
you know hitting 800
right it's an opportunity for your
shareholders it's an opportunity for
your taxpayers it's an opportunity for
your constituents
it's it's an opportunity in the media
business right i mean
nobody wants to talk about anything but
bitcoin
everyone wants to talk about bitcoin
it's an opportunity for twitter it's an
opportunity for every mobile app
what i think people don't recognize and
you and i have talked about this before
is um
it's the only thing from a strategic
standpoint that if you're an individual
you can plug in your personal balance
sheet right you can start to run your
own node you can use this technology if
you're a corporation or a financial
institution you can plug your business
into the network and you can do that in
a multitude of ways you can build
services that end up facilitating other
people to use it or
you can mine to support the network you
can simply just buy the asset and hold
it on your balance sheet but you can
plug in it's also true of nation states
and foundations and endowments and
pension funds et cetera but when you
plug into the network you're in essence
hiring tens of millions if not hundreds
of millions of people around the world
that are all now working aligned with
you to further your business right i
talk all the time about whether you're a
restaurant right where we've literally
seen examples of many restaurants who
have done this all the way up to large
pension funds or nation states
all of a sudden the the cyber hornets
online they begin to rally around you
they begin to push you forward they
begin to say hey we will support you
because you are like-minded like us you
are also helping us move this forward
but you also get the support of every
single minor in the world they'll say we
will protect your economic wealth for
you and you get the lightning network we
will help people actually route these
transactions
it's just a very unique thing where
you're essentially hiring so many people
and so much economic value but all you
do is you just plug in right you don't
have to go meet these people you don't
even know who they are it's an it's an
excellent political strategy it's an
excellent marketing strategy it's an
excellent shareholder relations strategy
it's an excellent business strategy uh
it's
i guess there's two thoughts i have here
one
properly understood
i believe bitcoin is digital energy it
is pure energy right it's not digital
gold that's put a billion dollars of
money in a vault and let's sit there for
a decade
and you can't do anything with it it's
it's it's not even digital property
digital property is a billion dollars of
a digital hotel and i can teleport it
from new york to paris and back again
and it's maintenance free and
indestructible it's better than that
it's digital energy because i can
decompose the hotel to room minutes
and i can i can decompose and recompose
this pure energy hotel and rent it out
at the speed of light and program it
with a million transactions a second you
never saw a hotel get programmed with a
billion parts a million transactions a
second it's literally like a swirling
energy mass
when you understand that
then you see
it hasn't eliminated capitalism it's
simply the 500
trillion dollar digital energy basis of
capitalism
it makes sense that you would use it as
the foundation to build your family to
build your company to build your country
to build your city to build your
application to build your device you can
put it into everything and now
once you've done that
look you can back up your your family
with the balance sheet of bitcoin you'll
be rich that doesn't mean you'll be
happy there's a lot of rich families
that have a lot of messed up problems
right you can watch them on television
you know you can put it on the balance
sheet of your company you know
i have you know seven if i have seven or
eight billion dollars on my balance
sheet that doesn't mean i don't have to
get up and go to work and make the
software work and sell the software and
listen to the customers i'm still in a
in a
competitive struggle with other
like-kind software companies it's all
business intelligence software
and the same is true with your city
right
it's half the solution the other half of
the solution is you need rational
policies at the municipal level the
state level and the government level so
when you think about it like that
right you realize that um
it it just it makes sense
and it's uh it's going to grow
but um
what was the second part of your
question again in terms of as more and
more people plug into this system do we
expect not only one the politicians
obviously will continue to do this but
is there a spillover effect where people
actually leave jurisdictions that aren't
bitcoin friendly like there's an element
of take taxes right there's a carrot and
a stick you can drop your tax rates you
can incentivize people to move but you
also could increase your taxes and
literally push people away
it's obvious that the incentive to get
people to move to your jurisdiction but
if people continue to be abrasive is
there problems yeah yeah i remember what
i was going to say now it's
the energy system is an energy network
everyone's plugging into it and it makes
them more efficient than they would
otherwise be but they still have their
struggle
what's happening is
yeah you're benefiting from the rest of
the network
you can't afford to to lose laser-like
focus on your family or company or
country right
you can't assume that just because you
plugged into bitcoin network you can be
a crappy retailer or a bad mayor or a
bad father right so it doesn't solve
that problem
every i think we boil down to
a simple idea which is everybody's got a
balance sheet everybody's got a p l the
p l is your operating business you
better be the best in the world at that
thing
the best in the world if you get
distracted you know you want to be a
good husband you can't have six wives
yeah you want to be a good retailer you
better know who your customer is you
still compete against every retail so
your operating
business you got to be really laser-like
and good at it but
by plugging your uh your balance sheet
into bitcoin
you have
hundreds of millions of people guarding
your back
that are energizing the network
and you know it takes me back to a
historic observation history teaches us
that the winning civilizations the
winners in the history of mankind
are the civilizations that channel
energy more effectively through time and
space
right and and that
means practically speaking right the
romans
they were good at killing people
it's not easy to kill people right i
mean to raise an army they didn't show
up with bows and arrows and spears they
showed up with industrial grade
artillery that tossed 50 pound flaming
balls of shrapnel at you from 500 meters
or a thousand meters away right and a
navy
so
so you see that over and over again
right
steel
trumps
iron and iron trump's bronze
and that's because and bronze trumps
stone
right you pick up a stone if you're if
you pick up the sharp rock you beat the
other guy if you're smart enough to pick
up a rock and the other guy didn't pick
up a rock you won the fight if you had
the had the iron then you beat the guys
with the bronze if you had the steel you
beat the guys the br with the the iron
you ever seen steel forged
people don't think about this walk into
a steel mill look around what do you
think is going on
right there they're channeling immense
energy right that the fire the heat you
know or electric electric rolled steel
massive energy into metallic form
air power is energy potential energy you
get up 50 000 feet you drop someone on
someone's head
okay what's the channeling part remember
the gulf war that you know norm
schwarzkopf used to show the videos of
the laser-guided bomb and something
that's in the clouds dropped the bomb
that managed to hit
you know a three by three
space
from
50 000 feet up you know through the wind
right so
the channeling of the energy through
time and space
you know and and being better at
channeling it that explains why every
team wins in sports that's why tom brady
wins because the quarterback puts you
seen him put the football
in exactly the spot you have to put that
football in that space in a plus or
minus 10 millisecond
time spot with the right uh with the
right spin on the ball and if you happen
to be able to do that you can win
and is it random no
it's not random there's one but one guy
that's better at it than everybody else
and and if he didn't have the team they
wouldn't win so
every winner
is better at channeling energy and time
and space every civilization every city
every company
right
every investor
so the real power of bitcoin
is
bitcoin is digital energy
and until you figure it out if i said to
you what is digital energy well digital
energy is i'm gonna put a hundred
billion dollars
into this container and then i'm going
to do a magic trick and it's not here
anymore but guess what i can move it at
the speed of light a billion times a
second and you can't find it and i can
put it into every car and it'll drive
every car on the planet for the next two
years without fuel
sounds like a magic spell
but it is a magic spell any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
bitcoin's digital energy
the next best thing is electrical energy
it's not you know information these are
not nearly as good it's a thousand times
better than the thing it's replacing a
lot of people
they can't get their head around it they
don't want to understand it
the conclusion is
if i told you like which country is
going to win the war
the one that masters
air power right the first half of world
war ii was air power you know sea power
the british would you know control the
seas right or how about this
nuclear power
what could nuclear power do for you
right you think you weren't channeling
energy
right you're channeling energy so now
we're talking about digital energy
and you would ignore it at your own risk
it
it doesn't guarantee you win right i put
a what's a gun a gun is is channeling
with precision
right chemical energy or explo explosive
energy right it's pretty obvious if you
think about it guns germs steel you're
channeling energy
you know
lord help you if you're on the wrong
side of that but if i do hand you the
gun you'll probably win unless you're
stupid enough to shoot your own foot off
and there are examples of people that
shoot their own foot off in you know in
the history of war and the history of
civilization
but ultimately what history's telling us
is the team that is most coordinated
that channels energy
always wins
and bitcoin bitcoin's a good bet just
because it's digital energy
and the advantage you have versus using
metallic energy in the form of gold
or using political energy in the form of
fiat paper
is so much greater
that um that the deck is just stacked
against everybody else
now the question is just who's going to
jump on it and how fast which politician
which big tech company right if apple
gets on bitcoin you know they generate a
trillion dollars of additional market
cap just on the balance sheet maneuver
that's the first trillion if they build
it into an iphone you make another
trillion if you're smart you have a 10
trillion dollar asset in your cloud and
you become a 10 trillion dollar bank
if they do it or they don't do it
right
the world's full of examples
of empires topple because they did not
embrace a new technology
you know the romans the romans needed
the etruscans to whiff you know
and uh and for the greeks to take their
eye off the ball and then you know one
thing leads to another and uh
when you get enough power you start to
you start to become more close-minded
if you have enough money and enough
power you don't need to learn anything
new
what we see going on right now is
every single powerful person in the
world is asked the question what do you
think of bitcoin
everybody the premier of you know of
russia every world leader every major
investor every major influencer
everybody's got to have an opinion
ask yourself the question
how many of them spend 100 hours
studying bitcoin to form an opinion
i don't think there's a single person
with a negative opinion that spent a
hundred hours studying it i mean i i
don't think you're out on the limb there
i just think
the world's full of people that don't
they haven't spent 10 hours studying it
and yet if i walked up to you in 1900
and i said
i got electricity
i want you to put it in your building
i want you to put it into your carriage
i want you to put it into your ship
i want you to you know you you
manufacture food
you know i want you to use electricity
instead of steam power or or mechanical
power
okay how many people would stop and
study it and how many would think they
would master it and figure it out with
one hour of consideration
would you know how to wire uh you know
hershey's pennsylvania you know or a
meat packing plant
you know or a ship with electricity and
a hundred hours
thousand hours how many hours does it
take to figure it out
and what are the consequences of not
figuring out
i think the consequences are
over 30 years
you go out of business right yeah
let me ask this um this idea of moving
energy between time and space i think
you and i uh unsurprising to the
audience uh understand how valuable this
asset is we understand how much pristine
collateral it provides when you think
about uh bitcoin there's a price that is
attached to it and the price goes up and
down on a daily basis it's priced in u.s
dollar terms um there are short-term
reasons why to pay attention to the
price especially if you're holding on a
balance sheet of a publicly traded
company like we talked about but when
you look out over the long term i've
heard you say things like uh it's going
up forever uh do not sell your bitcoin
and other things that uh i don't want to
make an assumption but insinuate that
you are going to hold bitcoin for your
lifetime how do you think about price in
that equation do you worry about it do
you think about uh what it will be worth
in us dollar terms in the future like
how do you think about price
i think the only thing you got to do is
figure out how much of it you can buy
and the reason to stop buying it would
be
you're buying it with leverage
or or with um
with a mark-to-market loan that could
cause you to get forced liquidated
so
if you had a million dollars sitting
around you just buy bitcoin and hold it
wait you know can you borrow 10 billion
can you borrow 10 million dollars to buy
bitcoin i i wouldn't buy it at 20 x
leverage or 10x leverage or even 5x
leverage or something
uh because
the significance of prices you look at
the volatility and you ask what's the
what's the
likelihood that it will trade down 50
and i'll get a margin call and force
liquidated
if you have margin debt you can
theoretically get a margin call
if you have long dated debt
you know uh if you have a seven year
loan we have a seven year loan and we
bought five hundred million dollars of
bitcoin at thirty six thousand dollars a
coin
what's the odds it'll be 36 000 a coin
in seven years
you know
i'm not so concerned about it so
i i
i think uh the way to think of it is
here's my model for bitcoin bitcoin's
price is going up because of inflation
safedeen says 14
right we know that
in the absence of everything else if you
had um if you had complete adoption if
eight billion people had bitcoin and
they and we had world currencies and the
us dollar was the world currency
and we inflated it 14 a year then you
would think bitcoin would go up 14
every year
as the currency kept getting inflated so
so the price of the dominant monetary
network or dominant monetary asset goes
up by inflation and the second the
second dynamic is adoption
there's a rip right that if there's a
hundred billion dollars of demand for
bitcoin then it's going to go up faster
than the 14 because there's a short
squeeze
as people are trying to buy the stuff
faster than the market wants to sell and
if you went from one percent adoption to
two percent adoption
you could imagine that the price could
double just because the adoption doubled
even in no inflation right correct
and then the third uh driver is utility
if um
this is common sense right you ever send
bitcoin to anybody else on the main
chain and you want to send 37 bucks and
it takes you an hour and
you got a fee and then when cash app
came out said you could just send it by
a hashtag
or you know
or you get a lightning that's the
proprietary way called layer three
and the layer two lightning ways i got a
lightning wallet and i zap it for one
satoshi in a split second remember the
big smile that brings to your face it's
pretty fun okay
did it not make you think that bitcoin
is more valuable like bitcoin's utility
explodes if i can move the money at the
speed of light on the layer 2 or the
layer three and if i can do a billion
transactions a day
or let's take el salvador right three
million people download a wallet and
they start doing remittances
is there demand for bitcoin
sure there is right so so as the
technical utility increases as we go
from
and by the way the technical utility
drives and feeds back into the adoption
right because there's three million
people in el salvador that now have
maybe a bit of bitcoin or the ability to
buy bitcoin in a split second that
couldn't buy it six months ago
so
if you look at a world going from 100
million people with what's low utility i
buy it i hold it for 100 years that's
low velocity
100 million adoption 200 million and i
move it every year 400 million 800
million 1.6 billion as the user count
increases
that's going to drive things but the
adoption's not just user count right
like if you're building the model you
would say well
how much money
people talk about they talk about uh
bitcoin and network fx and metcalf's law
okay again
if you're just looking at it in a
cursory way you're saying oh metcalfe's
laws apply but if you're thinking a bit
deeper about it you're thinking you know
newton's law is a pie right astrophysics
supplies
if you bring a hundred billion dollars
to the network and you're one person
that's more important than if you
brought a dollar to the network and
you're one person
and so you have to you have to do a
dollar weighted assessment of adoption
right and
and you would almost say
the value of it is a function of the
total amount of capital
plus the velocity right what's what's
the amount of money that shows up what's
the velocity of the money that shows up
what's the utility of the money that
shows up
and when you think about it that way
it becomes pretty clear that as we march
from one use case to a thousand use
cases
like you know holding it is one thing
least lending it out for yield is
another thing what if i put a lien on it
what if i can lock it up for five years
what if i can you know what if i can
create a trust what if i gave you a
trust that's good for the rest of your
life in the life of your firstborn child
for the next thousand years
and it's an app and i just fund it with
two bitcoin and you can't ever sell the
bitcoin but you can live off of the
yield of the bitcoin for the next
thousand years
it's an application right i can create
insurance policies i can create trust
funds i can what if i gave you a car a
tesla car and i put a bitcoin in the car
and the car refueled itself forever and
maintained itself it's a
self-maintaining car
more valuable than a non-maintaining car
right
it's like something it's like i hand you
uh something with an endowment
right yeah so
as as that happens
as you get more money flowing on the
network and more people flowing on the
network and more utility flowing on the
network the price goes up
and uh does it go up forever but why
yeah
because as i said it's the language of
money what's that mean it's like english
right how long's been around long time
it's like it's like it base 10 math
right like they're here's the thing
about it right people don't get this
part
bitcoin is is
is math but it's a type of math it's
like base 10 math the bitcoin protocol
is a protocol for money
now
i hand it to you you can either say
great this is the dominant protocol for
money this is the winner and i'm going
to buy as much of it as i can
or
you can keep trying to commercialize
base 16 math and base 32 math and base 2
math
and base format
and you know the
base 16 math
base 10 math is not the only
mathematical protocol any more than the
metric system is the only system of
measures it happens to be one that we
adopted there's no reason to think it
doesn't last a thousand years could last
10 000 years
right and that's the part that uh
that people don't get so when i say it's
going up forever
i'm saying well
if the
will the technology get better
obviously
will uh will adoption increase well i
guess you could say it gets pegged out
when adoption is eight billion people
when everybody's adopted it technology
keeps advancing
inflation continues in whatever other
currencies exist
and
at some point theoretically
if
all the other weak currencies failed
right you think we go from 130
currencies to 100 to 30 to 12 to 10 to
maybe one day there's the dollar in the
cny you're down to two and then maybe we
decide to throw away the dollar and the
cny we get enlightened and we just use
satoshi's yeah and you get the perfect
austrian economics hard money perfect
thing maybe it doesn't matter to me if
we do we don't but let's say we did
well then it goes up with the
productivity of the civilization right
right if the civilization is is got five
percent productivity growth
and everybody's adopted the same money
then you've got five percent growth
and until that you're going to have
faster than the productivity growth
because you're going to get these
these rips these uh these accelerations
from technology
and adoption and fiat inflation
in in the
in the frame of reference
right it's useful to see the frame of
reference right
is your frame of reference the peso is
it the boulevard is it the us dollar
and in that frame of reference then the
the price is going to adjust
my brothers are going to join us here in
a second to ask a couple of questions
sure uh but um my last question for you
uh on this topic is when you think about
microstrategy we always talk about
microstrategy right because that's the
company that you run
but a lot of people will forget you
actually made a very large personal
bitcoin purchase as well do you think
about a difference in the decision
making between a person optimizing for
this as like a balance sheet strategy
versus a corporation or do you see those
as the exact same thing
i think for a person you just you just
say how much money do i want to
store for the next decade or maybe hold
for life how much how much long duration
property if i said
i said
you're going to invest something for the
next 30 years and give it to your
grandchildren hold it in the family the
family endowment i would put that amount
of money in bitcoin
right
the rest of your money is an investment
you're betting on apple versus facebook
or it's a speculation i want to
speculate on doge versus ship because
it's fun or i want to gamble on the
outcome of the super bowl
because i think i know and it's fun okay
um and i think that that all
personal money falls into those three
categories it's either an investment
it's a speculation or it's a it's an
endowment of a savings account um
for a business that's different because
some businesses are traders if you're a
trader if you think you can out trade
someone else you're a business you
better be thinking about it 60 hours a
week you better have proprietary
computers and proprietary models and
know the markets and the arbitrages then
you could trade maybe i mean citadel
trades renaissance trades i mean
other people trade goldman sachs trades
so i i think they can be traders and
then also
when you get into business right
businesses have other options like maybe
they can raise capital they can issue
equity they can issue debt they're
publicly traded i i have an army of
lawyers and accountants so that i can do
that you don't as a family
so so businesses don't have the same
financing
capabilities sorry people on the same
financing capital as the businesses do
and then your business has strategic
assets
if your fidelity and you have trillions
of dollars of fixed income you can build
it into your bonds if you're a bank you
can build it into the bank if you have a
mobile app you can build it in a mobile
app if you build phones or devices you
can build it into the device
one thing i think with the business is
clear is
you just should be laser like focus and
you should think that
when the dust settles i need to be the
best in the world at what i do
right like for example
it wouldn't be a good idea for me to go
into business competing with fidelity
right they have 11 trillion in assets
i'm not go you know like i'm not going
to launch a bitcoin investment fund
right i'm not i mean it's not for me i'm
not going to go in business against you
know
square or paypal either just because i
think it's a good idea
so businesses need to be laser-like
focused on competing and growing and in
a creative fashion for their
shareholders and also businesses have
shareholders to manage and shareholder
relations and so
so there's that phrase you know if we
want to go far we need to go together
and so for a business it's very
important of shareholder alignment
would you rather have 10 billion dollars
of capital and get a 10 return
or no capital
and get a 30 return
right so a business has to keep their
capital aligned
and so a lot of times they'll do things
that are either optimized for their
shareholders or they're optimized for
their other constituencies and
businesses have uh regulatory nexus
right like there's certain things that i
can't do if i'm a bank in china right or
if i'm a bank in the u.s i can't so so
businesses have compliance issues
and individuals don't
so that's how you think about that
you don't know this but uh my two
brothers run the best business share
research team which is a very clever
thing that they came up with uh they
also run a union that i've busted like
20 times uh what questions do you guys
have
hopefully by the end of this we're going
to get uh michael to join the union
this will be our recruiting bitcoin's a
monetary union
he's in some monetary union you should
join eventually everybody else will
we're convinced what questions do you
guys have uh so i listened to the entire
interview fantastic awesome stuff but i
have to ask one question around
volatility so
you mentioned earlier you own
microstrategy owns or holds uh over a
hundred thousand bitcoin i think you've
mentioned in the past how much you
personally hold uh but there's days
where bitcoin is obviously appreciated
drastically over the last year 10 years
et cetera but bitcoin also went from 65
000 call to 30 000 or 32 000 this year
what's going on on days where you're
looking on paper and and it's going you
know hundreds of millions of dollars at
some points down
look
i'm running the business just like any
ceo is running the business like if you
were to ask jeff bezos you know what are
you thinking about on days when amazon
stock is down
it would say i'm not thinking about it
i'm thinking about fix the business run
the business and the stock will take
care of itself
and that's what i think i'm i'm looking
out for
seven years right i'm i'm saying how do
we educate more people on bitcoin what's
my next deal that i'm going to do i mean
if
if if my stock is down i'm going to
issue debt if my stock is up maybe i can
do a convert right what about the
software business how are we going to
deliver the best quarterly results we
can deliver you focus on the things you
can control so if i can control it i'm
going to do it
and
the short-term volatility
you know
you can't control
and so you just wait you
you gotta figure that in seven years the
market will sort itself out
in seven months it likely will sort
itself out and seven and
if you want to drive yourself insane
then you zoom in and if
if i zoom in close enough if i just look
at
0.001 percent of your face for 18
milliseconds
i bet i can find some protozoa bacteria
crawling around somewhere and it'll
freak me out
right if i if i want to right like it's
you're driving yourself to apoplectic
fits by
by inducing this anxiety
so the way i look at volatility is
actually the truth is i just say this
it's a benefit volatility is the price
you pay to get 10x the performance of
the s p
if it wasn't volatile
then would i have been able to borrow
2.2 billion dollars at one percent
interest and buy
seven and a half billion dollars worth
of it starting with 250 million in
capital
like
i
i like the fact it's hard i like the
fact it's scary i like the fact it's
volatile
what you really want
this is what you should hope for in life
you should hope that you can see the
future and you have a very strong
opinion about the future
but that everybody else disagrees with
you
and they're getting bounced around it's
a bumpy ride it's like i'm taking you on
a bumpy ride down the road i'm going to
bounce you this way in that way and in
five years
then there's a pot of gold at the end
and there's only two seats
and there's 10 people
and only two of you get on so the two of
you guys you're like oh there's pot of
gold at the end
i'm sorry part of bitcoin at the end
part of bitcoin at the end yeah you're
like okay well we'll sign up for the
bumpy ride what else do we got to do
and everybody else is like
fat dumb and happy and they've all got
plenty of everything and they're
comfortable in their life and they're
like well that doesn't look like a very
comfortable ride it's like you know a
jeep and it's a desert and it's a bumpy
ride we'll sit this one out can you just
bring it to us
and and it's you know what i said
tongue-in-cheek about the fdic statement
it's like when every bank can hold
bitcoin on their balance sheet well
then every company is going to borrow
hundreds of billions and trillions of
dollars against their bitcoin every
bank's going to buy trillions of dollars
of bitcoin the price is going to the
moon you're not going to afford the
bitcoin
when i make it
you know a smooth passage
you're going to wait until there's a
train or a plane that flies across the
country or you're going to get in a
wagon and you're going to go west young
man right
so i i'm like
the joke of course is
it's volatility but it keeps going
up people like
well how how else do you want it to go
up
right i mean like it's it's going up
with volatility so
i think it's a it's a benefit
because it it's volatility that pays off
everybody that does the research
and has any conviction
and it disproportionately benefits
people that want to make the investment
in the new world and uh and it transfers
wealth
away from people that are afraid of
volatility it's not really afraid of
volatility
it's
i mean amazon was volatile
right i mean a lot of people made a lot
of money on amazon a lot of people made
a lot of money even venture capitalists
you know accept extreme amounts of
volatility
i think here you have an example of a
liquid publicly traded asset which is
volatile
but
in fact
it's still
misunderstood by 98 of the public
investors so it's an asymmetric
opportunity to buy something which is
no less risky than investing in a big
tech company
but um but much less understood and i
think probably the sharp ratios would
actually bear that out because we looked
at volatility and
adjusted yield
john what questions you got yeah nice to
see you again michael um
so you have mentioned and i tend to
agree that bitcoin is digital gold and
it's a store of value i'm curious what
you're thinking is behind people
uh companies and other countries using
it as a medium of exchange we've seen el
salvador adopted what are your thoughts
around that
i i really think that
that
for the next decade this the screaming
home run architecture is
digital currency as the us dollar on top
of digital asset as btc
and i think that every country really
wants to move dollars around as the
medium of exchange
because 100 million companies have their
accounting systems wired for dollars
and i think they want to use the store
of value and
i
i think if you had a hundred dollars and
99 are invested in bitcoin and one
dollar is invested in the usd you have
99
of the benefit in fact it's not even
that it's like
you don't have to give up anything if
you have a million dollars you put a
million dollars into bitcoin and you
borrow a hundred thousand dollars in usd
a stable coin and then you pay your bill
in the usd while the bitcoin appreciates
so
the net balance sheet ratio is a hundred
percent
bitcoin but it doesn't make the
currency go away
right like micro strategies got more
than 100 of its balance sheet in bitcoin
but we still use the currency
so i what i think will happen if you
really want uh bitcoin adoption to take
off you don't want to squeeze out the
stable coins i think that the usd stable
coin is actually going to drive the
explosion in bitcoin the the use case of
stable coins up until now has been uh
crypto exchanges settling offshore right
there's they're settling crypto
exchanges
we didn't use stable coins at
microstrategy for anything we don't use
stable coins to buy bitcoin
right so what you want is you want eight
billion people to use a stable coin to
buy coffee
and you also want amazon and general
electric and apple to remit cross-border
treasuries in stablecoin
and why would you do that because you
can move money at the speed of light on
saturday afternoon for free and right
now microstrategy can't move money cross
borders at the speed of light for free
would we uh move usd by a stable coin
yeah would we move bitcoin well we might
flash it into bitcoin for a second move
it in another second flash it back into
usd right all uh you know strike you
know strike and jack mullers we might do
that
but i actually think that what the world
wants
not just the world
every consumer kind of every consumer in
south america africa would love to have
dollars in their wallet
they would also love
they know that now
everybody knows that now that's 100
right everybody knows they want dollars
in their wallet now so the us dollar
could spread to six billion people it
would spread to eight billion people the
chinese didn't block it right it'll
spread to all eight billion people now
they don't all know they want to hold
their life savings in bitcoin but that's
growing at a massive rate that's
spreading like a virus
every government knows they want to
control their currency
the strong governments will the us will
the chinese will the eu will
the weak governments won't right
afghanistan you know and uh you know
venezuela and places with hyper
inflation zimbabwe they will lose their
currency privileges because they're weak
and who will they lose them to to the
dollar
right so what i think is happening
is you're just going to see an explosion
in the dollar
an explosion in bitcoin
an explosion in demand for money moving
over lightning rails if you could move
stable coin over lightning rails that
would accelerate the growth of lightning
right yeah the killer the killer
application i want on my phone is a
lightning wallet with usd stablecoin
and then bitcoin and to be able to move
either of them at the speed of light in
a programmatic fashion
and i think they both win who loses and
this is the key like we i there's too
much the dollar must lose so bitcoin can
win no who loses is weak assets and weak
currencies can you think of a weaker
asset than bitcoin
every other investment asset
right especially gold silver commodities
land
stock weak value stocks and then and big
tech stocks they're all weaker assets so
you see money flow from there's 500
trillion of them by the way
right we have 500 trillion in weak
assets
if you got the 10 trillion from gold
we'd be up by a factor of 10. so i think
that uh weak assets flow to the strong
asset and then weak currencies how many
how many currencies in the world are
weaker than dollar
name one currency fiat currency in the
world stronger than the dollar none
they're all weaker cny is weaker every
african currency every asian currency
everything so 180 nominal currencies one
a lot of them are pegged to the dollar
130 floating currencies
they all they all can be replaced with
the dollar so
who wins
uh
western banks western technology
companies western hardware devices the
western world the united states western
europe
who wins everything embraces bitcoin
right who loses
you know the nation of gold
right i mean you want to declare a war
on something declare a war on gold they
don't have an army they don't have an
air force there's no politicians running
for office of president of gold
there's there's there's no city state
country no one is crying thinking that
their way of life will come to an end
if gold got demonetized so i you know if
i had won
one request from the bitcoin community
my request would be
focus your guns on gold
ultimately
gold is being demonetized this is not
speculation on the part of michael
saylor you have all the stats it's been
demonetized for the past decade
right it doesn't have a country it
doesn't have an army it doesn't collect
taxes there's not a single person on
earth
that is going to lie down in front of a
tank to defend the nation of gold
and yet gold is the enemy because gold
is a dumb rock sitting
you can't mortgage your gold you can't
lean up your gold it's hard to rent your
gold
or license it or develop it further
you know gold is not big tech you can't
put gold on an iphone
so ultimately what you have is
there are two things that should succeed
and grow
the us dollar if you live in the united
states and you believe in western values
and freedom and justice right and
western law and the progressive movement
you want the us dollar to grow and you
and instead of saying well the dollar is
like a problem to save and forget about
that just point out that if you live in
africa and asia you would give your left
arm to trade in dollars right so the
dollar should expand on on uh
lightning rails
and bitcoin should expand and they go
together
and we all win
there's no i mean we all win right the
world's a better place every company
everybody wins if you're going to
compete by the way if you're going to
compete with
square cash app
then you might lose
if you're going to compete with twitter
you might lose
if you're going to compete with the
united states of america
you might lose
my advice is
you don't got to destroy the banks you
don't have to topple a government you
don't have to crush a currency you don't
have to stop a regulator you don't have
to you know eliminate paypal
right you don't have to compete with all
of them you can buy bitcoin
you want to compete with something
declare war on a dead rock
right
declare war on the rock right the rock
has been losing for a while now and
after you're finished declaring warren
the rock declare war on on uh dead
property right dead money right what a
low velocity not
i don't want to hold 500 acres in the
middle of nowhere as a store of value i
don't want to hold five tons of rock as
a store of value
i don't want to monetize these things so
if you start thinking that way and you
think i just want to take my monetary
energy put it into digital energy and
then i want to partner an ally with
everything i find admirable every great
company every great politician every
great country right every great
technology
just be positive be constructive
and and we all go and we win together
the world will rebuild itself right it's
going to rebuild itself i would like i
would prefer that it rebuild itself in a
peaceful constructive cheerful fashion
as opposed to
you know someone's got to lose so i
could win i don't think everybody can
win right if we invent electricity and
we invent math and we invent fire isn't
it highly likely the entire human race
is better off because of math fire and
electricity right i think
right we can we can all win together and
so that's that's the way i see that
before we finish up uh we've been going
for two hours but i know you and i could
talk about this all day uh if i just
give you the floor to finish
when somebody says to you
why bitcoin what's your you know two
three four sentence answer as to
why has michael saylor uh who had every
option in the world to buy an asset put
on your balance sheet or personally
invest in why bitcoin
because
the most
i'd start by saying the human condition
is elevated via the channeling of energy
and every great advance
was a new form of energy via metallic
energy in the form of steel or
electrical energy or chemical energy
and uh and bitcoin is the next evolution
of that
right so the first reason is
it's compelling
um
[Music]
and critical to the events of the human
race the second observation is every
successful investment idea in the 21st
century was a digital transformation
digital transformation of music digital
transformation of of uh entertainment
digital transformation of books digital
communications
bitcoin's the digital transformation of
everything else everything that didn't
get tran that didn't get transferred uh
transformed in the
in the first
in a chapter of the mobile wave comes
next
so now we have digital transformation of
gold
digital transformation of property
and digital transformation of energy
and for the first time in the history of
the human race you can literally take
energy transform it into something in
cyberspace store it forever move it at
the speed of light
program it
and eliminate the friction
that that is applied to
to that energy when it takes another
form
economically energy is capital right we
we use the phrase capital
if you've got digital capital it's the
digital transformation of capital and
capital is half of everything
if you sum up every piece of property
every corporation the value of
everything it's all capital you
capitalized it
so if i capitalize everything
and i stored it in 20th century
instruments
i would store it i would store them in
equity securities and bonds and and
titles to property
in the 21st century i have the chance to
capitalize the entire world economy and
put it in a digital token we call
bitcoin
so why why and buy it because
because uh
it's half of everything
right
it's hot it's literally half of
everything and
it is the platform it's the it's the
foundation upon which we build the 21st
century
economy
you could say 21st century cyber economy
but
if you want to fix everything in the
world
if i could eliminate the friction
move everything at the speed of light
make it immortal
oscillate it at 60 megahertz or faster
you know execute a million transactions
a second and make it infinitely
intelligent wouldn't you think
that uh that would be a good idea
right the future capitalism
there's not very many people who believe
in this more than i do but uh you may be
one of them because i think you and i
see eye to eye on all of this so i
appreciate you taking the time to come
in here uh i appreciate you two sitting
around and watching this entire thing
coming and asking some questions
they'll be taking virtual laps for weeks
now because you even hinted at the fact
that you may be open to joining their
union uh i appreciate everyone uh
watching at home uh please make sure you
like the video subscribe to the channel
thank you to sofi for sponsoring the
best business show
and uh we have lots and lots to go over
after this conversation but uh we'll be
back tomorrow and uh i think that's it
go follow michael on twitter
i don't know if we've got anything else
i don't know if thanks for having me i
don't know if you need any more twitter
followers but i got one more question oh
we talk about don't ask me what the
price is going to be no i won't ask you
i'm not tired of that question no we
talk about bitcoin being good for
business all the time and i think part
of that is obviously the price has
appreciated so anyone who has been
involved has uh has benefited from that
but part of it is also just the
community aspect of it right and how
powerful that is is there a specific
point in time where you were like holy
crap like this is wild these people are
really strong they're really passionate
you know
i think that every single month that's
gone by i've just been
more impressed with the community ethos
i if you look at our press release when
we first bought bitcoin and we said why
we bought it
uh one of the lines we put in the in the
press releases were persuaded by the
community ethos but
by the community itself
that um that this is digital gold and
it's harder and it's smarter and it's
stronger and it's faster
than gold
and i think that came out of all my
research before we actually made that
announcement and there
the way you figure out the community's
passionate is you do your research and
you study all the influencers you look
at all the podcasts and you read all the
books
and you couldn't come to any conclusion
other than
the
the asset is
differentiated based on the community
ethos
i even i even tweeted this i made this
point and i guess i elaborated right now
i said
you know the character
of the asset determines the decision the
dust sorry the character of the of the
owners
determines the destiny of the asset
right the character of the people that
own something
if you own like
joe random yo-yo coin and you're owning
it to flip it on saturday night
depending upon which way a football game
goes
okay
that's the the destiny of the asset
right it's going to be short-term
because the people are short-term if the
whenever you buy anything you gotta ask
yourself the question what's the
character and what's the intent and
what's the strategy or the belief system
of the people that are buying the thing
that i'm buying
if i buy real estate in new york
right you'll eventually sell it to
someone else who swears that new york is
the apex city people that love new york
their opinion is there is no other city
on earth where you could go everything
is a step down they have a view of new
york as mount everest and they're living
at the top of it and everything
if you were to say have you ever
considered moving to another city they
recall in horror
you know kind of like new york is like
the rome
of 100 a.d and there's rome and then
there's barbarians
okay so that's the character of the
asset owner
what's the character of people that own
bitcoin if you have if everybody bought
it because
because they intend to hold it forever
isn't that the kind of asset you want or
if i told you people bought it because
they liked the monogram
the you know this they own that dog well
how many dog coins are there
48 or something
well
if you bought the 47th dog coin
then the 49th dog coin is eventually
going to demonetize you
so i i think that's been very clear from
the beginning
uh
bitcoin had the immaculate conception
right i mean you can't recreate this
again how do you have a an open sourced
you know
asset that was never pre-mined that was
never ico'ed
that no you know no one thought would be
that until it became that right
so i
i think that um
i think that my conviction grows with
time
but it's pretty evident in august all
right so what's your print knobs
do you have a price prediction
it's going up forever
all right listen i appreciate everyone
coming i thank you very much michael
yeah uh you uh you've got a whole bunch
of stuff you guys spending your time on
so i appreciate you coming here hanging
out with us and uh anyone's got any
questions go tweet at michael he
probably will not respond but he'll at
least read it so uh see you guys
tomorrow have a good one
thank you
you